[Musique]
Hercule Poirot j'ai quelque chose pour
vous
je suis la personne la plus intelligente
que je connaisse et je n'y comprends
rien j'ai besoin d'un deuxième cerveau
vous vous avez une idée derrière la tête
j'ai vu des milliers de médiums tous des
charlatans
je ne crois pas aux médiums
venez assister à une séance dévoiler
l'escroquerie
détective vous venez pour me discréditer
n'est-ce pas mais moi je parle aux morts
je donnerai tout pour entendre ma fille
si quelqu'un veut s'exprimer
nous sommes là
à l'écoute
maman
[Musique]
vous n'allez pas nous enfermer ici une
femme est morte
personne ne sortira tant que je n'aurais
pas le coupable
un fantôme l'a tué
il doit y avoir une explication
rationnelle à tout cela
admettez pour une fois que la situation
vous dépasse
vous disiez
quelque chose à tenter de me tuer
vous n'oserez pas me suspecter nous
sommes de vieux amis
tous les meurtriers ont de vieux amis
personne ne sortira avant que je sache
si les morts tu les vivants
tu étais
à qui parlez-vous
[Musique]